so he's uh just talking about um there
was some dispute or some people rumors
going about something about manchester
united etc
from a juvenile when my clothes had
holes in them
and my afro was picky to the nighties
moschino and versace no laces in aurora
cheese
new millennium sorry come guys hope you
guys want to show that yep the camera's
gonna be a little bit shaky because i'm
a little bit on the go so as you guys
can see paul
pogba pogba yes footballers i don't know
i don't know their name i don't know
what team they play for i don't know
what enough is going on uh but as you
guys can see on the screen a little
screen or stream uh that paul pogba so
he's
uh just talking about um there was some
dispute or some people rumors going
about something about manchester united
etc
false rumors etc whatever it may be and
as muslims we know that to spread false
rumors no matter we're not talking about
slander but in general whatever it may
be it's not nice
it's even crosses backbites and talking
about someone that they don't like to
hear
so with this issue i don't know how big
it was but you can see that he wrote
hashtag speak the truth or remain silent
uh subhanallah so he could have and i'm
sure he's talking about the hadith of
the prophet salallahu sallam
because he himself said that even though
his mom practiced islam
she didn't teach them or something so he
sees himself as a reaver so he came
to islam he went hajj or umbra as far as
i know and handle it seems like his
religion plays a
close role uh plays a very big role in
his life
so the prophet sallallahu alaihi said
speak good
or remain silent and this is very
important for every single one of us
broken sisters a lot of the times we say
things we do not understand how
it's how sharp our tongues can be uh to
one another be it to a husband to a wife
or the wife to a husband or to your
brother or to your
even your parents subhanallah even your
kids it's damaging
you know even if you say something to
your kids you don't realize so
like the prophet peace be upon him said
and i appreciate and value that paul
pogba is in
incorporating or or um
having a part of his life to have the
hadith of the peace prophet peace be
upon him
speak good or just remain silent yeah
and
never and there was a scholar i can't
remember who it was but he said never
have i regretted
i've many times regretted words that
i've said but i've never regretted being
silent
and subhanallah this is a reminder for
me as well sometimes i talk a bit too
much
and sometimes i just need to be you know
quiet so that's it i want to share that
with you guys and shall i keep it very
nice and short
um and inshallah you guys as well please
incorporate this in your life just as
paul pogba
is doing speak good or remain silent
like the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said till next time
see you guys soon i'm on the run